[Voce fuoricampo, dal trailer del film "Star Wars: il risveglio della Forza"] «There is been an awakening. Have you felt it..?»
Direi... che è stata una buona idea, fare questo video.
♪♫♪ [In sottofondo, il motivetto jazz che funge da sigla alla serie "Late Show con Karim Musa"] ♪♫♪
Benvenuti ad una nuova puntata del "Late Show con Karim Musa". E quindi, alla fine, ci siamo: il "video dei video".
Per chi non lo sapesse, nel video precedente avevo chiesto alla gente di mandarmi delle
clip ( di pochi secondi) a tema horror, con dentro una clip che ho personalmente messo a disposizione.
E figurati se io non mi sia "cagato addosso"  al pensiero di questo esperimento; perché, tutti noi sappiamo benissimo che fine fanno
le clip in green screen, nell'eventualità che le si dia in pasto a Internet.
[Musica]
Cazzo, se ho detto che lo sappiamo... lo sappiamo! Non c'è bisogno di far vedere alcun file .rvm ...
Devo dire, però, che mi avete stupito: io qui lo dico e qui lo nego,
non ho mai riso così tanto in vita mia guardando tutto quello che mi avete mandato.
E, oggi, vi mostrerò le migliori tra queste; in quello che tutti avete pensato fosse un video speciale per Halloween...
...quando, in realtà, vi ho gabbati, vi ho fregati: non è un video speciale per Halloween. Ma, invece, è uno speciale per commemorare gli undici anni di esistenza del canale.
Non so per quale motivo non ve lo abbia detto prima: forse per far sì di lasciare che tutto fosse il più naturale possibile.
Però, a Ottobre si è compiuto il mio undicesimo anno d'esistenza del canale; direi che sono tanti...
E questo video risulta essere quasi un regalo che vi faccio: per ricordarvi che siete voi i protagonisti di questo canale, esattamente quanto lo sono io.
Quasi: tutti i soldi me li "pappo" io, però; voi guardate, e basta.
Sapete da cosa ho avuto modo di capire che si era partiti col piede giusto, con questo video..?
Perché la primissima e-mail che mi è arrivata altro non risultava essere che un enorme "wall of text" della parola "peni", ripetuta ovunque.
Peni, peni, peni...ovunque.
Questa è stata la prima cosa che mi è arrivata: miglior pubblico di Youtube Italia, baby..!
"Because this is thriller, thriller night/
and no one is gonna save you/ from the beast about to strike./
You know this is thriller, thriller night."
Sì, sì, questa clip risulta essere veramente horror: provate a farla vedere a qualche Youtuber, e poi ditemi se non si sarà cagato addosso dopo averla guardata.
C'è da dire che moltissime clip, non risultavano essere neanche a tema horror; ma, cavolo.. se siete stati bravi.
«Alzati.»
[In sottofondo, la folla sugli spalti esulta]
Veramente bravi!
Qui ci sono io come protagonista del film "Interstellar",
qui ci sono io come protagonista del film "Uccelli",
qui ci sono io all'interno della copertina del film "Alba Kiara"
(sono lì - non so se si vede).
Però, sono fiero di voi:
perché nessuno mi ha mandato una singola clip con "Birdemic"; ma neanche mezza, eh..! Anche perché, sarebbe stato facilissimo realizzare una clip banale di "Birdemic".
Ma nessuno me ne ha mandato neanche mezza: ci sono quasi rimasto male.
Però, me ne sono arrivate un paio di belle con "IT": una dove ho anche
Il naso rosso e il rossetto (cazzo, s hai fatto un lavoro di "tracking" della Madonna - complimenti!);
e con l'altra sono scoppiato a ridere, quando l'ho guardata, perché non è un trailer del film "IT"... ma un trailer di "YOT".
[Risate forzate]
Non so se avete avuto modo di capirla, mannaggia...
Per alcuni, l'inferno non è composto d'altro che da gattini: gattini ovunque, direi.
Per altri, invece, consiste semplicemente in una porta tra le fiamme, che si apre nel buio... e con all'interno le tendenze di Youtube Italia .
Hai capito, gli intenditori...
E, poi, uno mi ha inserito all'interno di uno dei vecchi intermezzi pubblicitari mandati in onda su Rete 4.
[Musica rete 4]
Uno dei miei sogni nel cassetto.
In questa e-mail c'è scritto solamente: "vaffanculo negro".
Poi...
È semplice, ma funziona: mi piace.
E, poi, ci sono quelli che su queste clip ci hanno speso del tempo per realizzarla: infatti, lo si denota perché sono horror, e sono ottime. Bravi, bravi!
«Oh, Karim: carissimo Karim. Adesso ti spieg- no, calmo Karim. Calmo, ti spiego... Karim..? Karim!»
Altri, invece, molto meno...
[In sottofondo: ] «Signora, c'è un uomo per lei»
Guarda, manda un abbraccio alla tua famiglia; e ti auguro tanta, ma tanta fortuna per il futuro.
Uno ha compreso perfettamente quale sia il mio incubo: quello di finire in "Google Immagini", in mezzo ai miei meme.
"It's a-me, Influencer!"
Ce ne sono alcune che hanno una cura per i particolari, che non ve la immaginate...
Ora, immaginate di essere un adolescente squattrinato durante i saldi di Steam: il vero orrore..!
Dio, in quei momenti vorresti morire.
Di questa, non posso dire niente: adoro il piede di porco nella mano.
Questa prossima clip potrebbe turbare le persone più sensibili; per cui, ho voluto avvertirvi.
[Canzone russa]
No, non c'era la censura: l'ho aggiunta io.
[Canzone russa ]
Non so... cosa dire.
Voi, ormai, mi conoscete benissimo: perché sapete che adoro i colpi di scena finali.
Sono lì, che mi guardo una semplice clip ambientata nel mondo di Isaac, quando ad un certo punto...
All'improvviso, dal nulla... boom, così! Come colpo di scena, ecco un enorme testone di Sabaku che ti guarda con gli occhi che brillano.
Era un bel colpo di scena: si. Cozzava bene con la clip: assolutamente no.
E, a proposito di Sabaku, è stato così tanto gentile da mandarmene una:
in essa, mi ha fatto finire in un'altra dimensione in compagnia di Rick & Morty.
[Voci in radio inglesi]
Veramente di classe: grazie!
E, a proposito di Rick & Morty...
Perché no, voglio dire... Vi adoro!
Anche il buon Gatto me ne ha mandata una: mi ha fatto disintegrare dai tripodi del film "La guerra dei mondi".
Almeno, ho conosciuto Tom Cruise.
«E voi?
[In coro: ] «Io ci sto.»
No... Soltanto no.
Qualcuno ha usato il mio indirizzo di posta elettronica... per creare un account di Pornhub.
Questa clip di "Stranger Things" è molto carina; però, permettimi di darti un consiglio.
Voilà.
Poiché le persone hanno un sacco di fantasia, mi sono arrivate qualcosa come duemila clip su "Sharknado".
Ma, tra tutte, questa è la più bella:
trattasi di uno "schermo verde invertito", ovvero ha lasciato lo schermo verde e ha tolto me (inserendo all'interno della mia silhouette una locandina di "Sharknado").
Ti voglio molto bene.
Questa clip, invece, è falsa: perché io, mai e poi mai scapperei da Goldberg. Mai...
Goldberg: "aaahh"
E, per finire questa splendida carrellata di clip, eccovi il genio.
Jerry Scotti «Signori, buona sera!»
Jerry Scotty: aahh, ahhh
[Sbam]
[Risate del pubblico]
«Ma...ma.. come è possibile, una cosa del genere..?!?»
E, siccome siamo alla fine di questo video, io dovrei farvi dei ringraziamenti:
dei ringraziamenti enormi, per tutti questi anni di lavoro... tutti questi anni di passioni... tutti questi anni di soddisfazioni, che ho avuto anche grazie a voi.
Dovrei ringraziarvi, perché mi permettete di avere un lavoro che mi piace e (conseguentemente) di vivere una vita decente;
ma, non lo farò.
Al loro posto, vi faccio vedere questo.
[Canzone russa]
Lo so: lo so, che l'ha già fatto Pewdiepie. Non rompetemi le balle, porca put-!
«Ambarabà...
Cicì.. Coccò.»